what the [ __ ] revenue don't have this
light all right yeah it is delay his P
was like green oh wait like a boss talk
to culprit meet a giant fish [ __ ] his
brains out if you type in YouTube
PewDiePie it will show up PewDiePie PMS
it's pretty weird like PewDiePie PMS
yeah
that's my thing PMS that's my profession
that's my expertise another character I
guess probably I mislead um that's what
it is
oh [ __ ] that bad not cool see ya alright
let's use a chariot
oh sweet son of a ditch
they got a lot of works for son of a--
he just takes it like a mane let's kick
him out of here
see ya see ya oh [ __ ] the motto
I am taking comer bloody screen so real
that's what she said I don't know what
you were referring to
you scared the dick go what the [ __ ] is
up with the dialogue it's like the
weirdest [ __ ] ever
okay what song you wanted missing then I
know I'm talented jeez I could be the
next Bieber you know I'm just saying oh
[Music]
come on quad came to the quad oh my
freaking lo cual kick penetration there
we go like a boss see no problem that
was easy
yeah
hey don't copy my others more
see I kept 'miss now oh well I guess I
can't miss one no am i doing it wrong I
don't get it
it won't [ __ ] die
oh there they are it's like 20 seconds
delay ice
[Music]
I don't know you guys are treating me
like a [ __ ] like good job beauty you
did it yeah thanks that's pretty easy
get boom hey oh [ __ ] I really want to
kill that thing
no no not again I suck at this game
what's wrong
no I gave back to treating me like a
[ __ ] space to continue
Asian guys scared me one's missing Oh No
Godzilla's loose
oh good Salah God said ah they're
supposed to die
alright I'm doing pretty good here I
haven't died in like forever
yeah well isn't it like different from
say the state on what age you should be
I don't know
well
they probably whatever God's Allah God
ha ha
what's he doing when I was [ __ ] you
okay now what what the hell
Oh is a robot I thought it was Godzilla
interact what the hell does that mean
oh he trapped me stupid Godzilla
I guess smash Oh
Godzilla's my i'm trapped now stupid
good so uh can i I can't do anything I'm
stuck
no it's not cool [ __ ] talk to me
cut damn what am I supposed to do
okay shoot here I can't kill me oh well
I guess I got already started that
chapter no not the shot there checkpoint
who else close